everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem coin change2 we
already solved the first one and i'll
link that somewhere on the top right of
the screen or somewhere in the
description if you want to watch that
video you don't have to solve it before
solving this problem but it'll probably
be easier to solve this problem if you
do so similarly we're given a list of
coins each representing a different
amount right a different denomination
and we're given a second parameter an
integer amount and this is the amount
that we want to sum up to it's a total
amount of money that we want to sum up
to given these coins and specifically we
want to know with these coins and this
particular amount how many different
combinations are there that we can sum
up to this amount of course if we can't
ever sum up to that amount we can just
return zero and we can assume that we
have an infinite number of each type of
coin so
that kind of hints to you that this is
an unbounded knapsack problem which i
talk about that category of problem in
one of my videos i think it's called top
five dynamic programming patterns if you
want to watch that video and so this is
kind of one example that they give us
and you can go ahead and read it if you
want there's four different ways to sum
up to the amount five if we're given
three coins one two and five now when we
say number of combinations we can't
reuse the same combination right so if
we get two to one uh two two one these
three coins sum up to five we can't just
change the order and then call that a
different combination the order doesn't
really matter so now let's kind of get
into the explanation let's talk about
the brute force explanation which is
going to be exponential with uh c to the
power of n whereas c is let's say the
number of coins that we have and n is
the total amount that we want to sum up
to that's the exponential solution we
can uh use memoization on that decision
tree to actually get the time complexity
to be big o of uh c times n i'm actually
just gonna replace the variable c with m
so let's call it m to the power of n
that can be reduced to m times n uh this
time complexity that's the best time
complexity we can do but there is one
optimization with memory complexity
that's pretty difficult to come up with
but i'll kind of explain it to you so
let's get into that so same example
we're trying to get the amount five with
these three coins let's just think about
the brute force so
initially we have a sum of zero right
we'll put that in a node and we have
decisions we can make right we're just
gonna
make three decisions right we could
either choose a coin of one that that
would give our sum to be one uh we can
either choose a coin of two that would
give our sum to be two we could choose
another coin to be five
that would put our sum to be five right
and then we can continue this approach
the only thing is how do we guarantee
that we don't have duplicates
right because if i go down this path and
i choose another two and and then i
choose another two right here we have a
one two two that gives us a sum of five
so that gives us the amount that we
wanted here we could do the same thing
couldn't we we could get a one and then
we could get a two this is the same uh
combination of coins just a different
order right we don't want to get into
this case so how can we guarantee with
this decision tree that we won't ever
get something like that well how about
every time we make a decision
right we made three decisions in this
case we put some rules on that decision
how about
when we go down this path we are allowed
to choose we chose a one right we chose
the coin one and we're allowed to choose
any coin that we want right down this
path we can continue to choose a one we
can choose a two we can choose a five if
we want but we want to make sure that
this never gets any duplicates as this
one so how can we guarantee that how
about this path can never
choose a one how about we just don't let
us choose ones anymore down this path to
make sure that we never have duplicates
on the other side of the decision tree
right we're free to choose any twos and
any fives that we want but we just can't
choose once hopefully it makes sense why
that guarantees that we won't have
duplicates right because this path has
at least one one right and this path
will never have any one so obviously
neither both of these paths will never
have the same combination i hope that
makes sense and similarly over here when
we choose a five we're gonna we're gonna
say that okay we're not allowed to
choose anything except fives right we
can't choose ones or two that'll
guarantee that these two are not the
same right because we have a two here
and we'll never have any twos down this
path so they'll never be the same so
that's the main idea of how i'm going to
eliminate duplicates so now we've gotten
to the point where we have the m to the
power of n solution right the base case
is going to be if we get to the amount
so you can see on this path we already
reached the amount right we have a total
of five that's exactly the target that
we're trying to get to
now let's say we chose a five over here
right we chose a coin of five that would
put our total at seven if we go over the
total amount then we're going to stop
right then we're just going to return 0
and then stop going down that decision
so those are the main base cases and by
the way how are we going to implement
that idea of if we chose a 1 or chose a
2 we're not allowed to choose any other
certain coins right we're gonna be
maintaining a pointer uh let's call it i
it's gonna point at some index of coins
right so if we chose a coin of one then
our index is going to be here right at
the coin one and if we chose a coin of
two then our index i is gonna be at this
coin two and what when when our index is
at a coin then it basically means that
we're not allowed to choose any coins
with an index less than it so basically
anything on the left side of this coins
array on the left side of our pointer i
we're not allowed to choose those coins
right so that's how i'm going to
implement it in the code and this is
important because now that we actually
move into the memoization solution the
memoization solution where we're going
to be caching the repeated work because
when you look at this decision tree it's
going to be pretty inefficient right
like i said it's going to be m to the
power of n where m is the number of
decisions we can make in other words
it's the number of coins that we have n
is the total amount right because the
amount is what's going to determine the
height of the tree so when we implement
this recursively let's call it dfs we're
going to pass in two parameters one
parameter is going to be i which is
going to tell us what index we're at in
coins it could be you know any of these
uh positions
and we're going to pass in a second
parameter let's call it a which is
whatever the current amount happens to
be remember if the amount ever goes over
five which is you know the target that
we're trying to do then we're going to
stop right so basically the total number
of about possible values a could be is
going to be whatever that target value
is so when you look at this right how
many different combinations could this
dfs be called basically the total number
of coins that we have right let's call
that m and the total amount that we're
trying to sum up to let's call that n so
the total possible number of ways this
dfs could be called is m times n so if
we cache the repeated work right if we
call it with the same values we don't
wanna have to recalculate the same thing
if we call dfs let's say uh on index one
and let's say our amount happens to be
two and we call this multiple times we
don't wanna have to recalculate all that
work so we can do caching with that so
that's basically memorization we're
going to be putting that in memory and
then we won't have to redo that work so
at this point we've gotten to a solution
that will pass on leak code the time
complexity will be m times n and the
memory complexity will be the same but
now i'm going to show you the dynamic
programming solution which will actually
have the exact same time and space
complexity and then i'm going to show
you a slightly more advanced dynamic
programming solution which will actually
reduce the memory to instead of being o
of m times n it'll actually be o of n
this is one of the reasons why dynamic
programming is important because
sometimes the dynamic programming
solution can actually be more efficient
than the recursive memorization solution
so if you want to check that out
continue so now let's do the dynamic
programming solution you can see i drew
a 2d grid where we have one dimension
being the amount the you know zero from
zero all the way to up to five and one
dimension being the coin we had three
different coins one two three and we
know the base case is if the amount is
zero right and what value are we gonna
put in here when the amount is zero how
many different combinations is it that
we can sum up to zero well the base
cases let's just put it as one right
because that's what's gonna make the
math work out and it kind of makes sense
right how many ways can you sum up to
zero just one right regardless of which
coin we start at so what does this
position mean it means that if we could
only choose from this single coin five
how many different ways could we sum up
to zero it's going to be one different
way right and this position is going to
mean if we had two coins available to us
two and five how many ways could we sum
up to the amount zero it's going to be
one right and so on and so on for an
arbitrary position like this the
question is uh how many different ways
can we sum up to the amount three using
these two coins from here it would be
using these three coins right so what
order would it make sense to uh compute
these values probably bottom up right
that's why they call this bottom-up
dynamic programming we're going to start
here and compute the value that goes
here then we're going to compute the
value that goes here and then here and
then start from here and then do the
same and looking at it since we're doing
it in this order you're probably
thinking i probably should have you know
rotated this instead i should have put
the amount over here and the coins over
here because then we can actually
compute it like
this and you're right but there's
actually a way that we can compute it
like this
that i'm going to show you and actually
this way if we do it in this order is
going to be better memory complexity let
me show you why that's the case though
so let's say starting from this position
right we're trying to sum up to the
amount one if we use a coin we can only
choose one coin that's available to us
right we can choose a five coin what
happens if we use a five coin uh then
our amount that we're trying to sum up
to is gonna be one minus five right
that's going to put us at negative four
so from here i'm gonna go to negative
four now that's out of bounds right so
that kind of tells us that there's zero
ways to sum up to the amount one if we
only have a single five coin available
to us next let's compute the value that
would go here so we have two choices in
this case actually because now we have
two coins available to us so we can
choose to use the two coin what happens
if we use the two coin well then our
amount one is going to be one minus two
which is going to be negative one right
so you know if we're trying to get the
value here then you know our arrow is
going to go over here out of bounds
which is negative right so that doesn't
work and that's if we choose the two
coin if we choose the five coin what
what are we going to do well then we're
just going to look directly below us
because we're still solving the same
problem amount equals one but in this
case we're choosing not to use the two
coin we're just gonna use the five coin
but we see that that's a zero value down
here so in the end we'll also end up
putting a zero here and from here we're
going to do the same thing we in this
case we have three coins available to us
if we use a one coin what is that going
to put us well we started at we're
trying to get to the amount one if we
use a one coin we'll do one minus one
equals zero so okay then from here we're
gonna you know go to the to the spot
that has a value of zero right that's
directly to the right of us right that's
where zero is so then we're gonna take
this value add it to this position right
so one is gonna be added here but we
don't have to choose this one coin right
we could actually choose the two coin we
could ask okay instead of choosing one
what happens if we try to sum up to the
value one with two coins available to us
in that case we look directly below us
and we see that there's a zero there and
we add zero to this position one plus
zero will just be one so we can leave a
one in this spot so and then you can
kind of just continue doing the dynamic
programming just like this one thing you
might notice though let's assume for an
arbitrary position like this one if we
use the two coin that'll put us amount
is four we'll move two spots to the
right where amount is two right so we're
looking all the way to the right we
could also say okay we're not going to
use the two coin right we're gonna use
all the other coins in that case we'd
have to look directly below us right
that's perfectly fine this this
perfectly works but one thing you're
noticing for a arbitrary position like
this one we have to look both to the
right and we have to look below what
does that mean that means potentially we
have to have the entire uh
two-dimensional array in memory because
when we're looking directly to the right
of us we're not just looking one spot we
could be looking two spots three spots
five spots right depending on what coin
value we have so in that case we're
going to have to have this entire
two-dimensional grid in memory there's
actually a different way we can do this
problem if we uh compute this in this
order right from here in that way we
won't have to have the entire grid in
memory we will only have to have up to
two rows uh two rows like these we'll
only have to have up to two rows in
memory and a row will only be as large
as whatever the max amount happens to be
which means the overall memory
complexity in that case will be big o of
n now you probably don't need this
solution to pass your interview unless
it's like a super hard interview and
your interviewer is looking for it but
i'll show you both of the solutions
anyway i'll show you the code for this
solution and the code for the memory
solution of o of m by n okay so in this
spot we're asking the same question
if we only have one coin available to us
can we sum up to the amount one we can't
write because then we go out of bounds
so in this case let's just put a zero
okay ask the next question if we're
summing up to amount two with just one
coin available to us can we sum up to
that amount no of course we can't right
so and that's gonna be true for this
position right can't sum up to three
can't sum up to four either but once we
finally get to five with a single coin
of five well what's going to happen okay
we use our coin of five right so that
means we look five spots all the way to
the right and over here in this spot we
find a one is waiting for us right
that's our base case that's where amount
is equal to zero so we take that one and
then we add it in this spot right so now
we've done that so there's one way to
compute the the amount of five if we
only have a single coin available to us
but remember the actual problem that
we're trying to solve is all the way in
the top left corner if we had all three
coins available to us because we do we
have an unlimited supply of all three
coins available to us so how many
combinations can we do to get to this
amount five well let's continue row by
row just like i mentioned right so now
we will need to keep this row in memory
for us to be able to compute this row
but once we're computing this row we
actually won't need this bottom row in
memory anymore and i'll show you why
that's the case so now if we had two
coins available to us how many ways
could we sum up to the amount one well
if we use a two coin we'll go two spots
to the right which is out of bounds so
we don't put anything right so far it's
we're at zero so if we choose not to use
the two coin and we say okay we're just
going to use all the remaining coins
then we look directly below us again we
find a zero so in this spot we say that
there are zero ways to sum up to the
amount one if we have these two coins
available to us which makes sense right
there's no way you can get a one if you
have a two and a five available to you
now let's do it in this spot so if we
use the two coin in this spot we'll move
two spots to the right which will we
find a one here right so we can add a
one here uh if we choose not to use the
two coin we look directly below us which
is a zero so we don't do anything in
that case right so we leave a one here
there's one way to sum up to the amount
two with uh these two coins available to
us
in now i'm going to start going fast
because i don't want to waste too much
your time so in this spot we're gonna
look directly two spots to the right
which is a zero or we're going to look
directly down and that's a zero so we'll
still put zero here notice how we're
looking multiple spots to the right but
that's okay because we have this row in
memory but when we look down we're never
going to look multiple spots down that's
the key that's why we only need o of n
extra memory so let's continue so from
amount four uh we're going to look two
spots to the right there's a one or
we'll look down that's a zero so we put
one plus zero one here here again two
spots to the right that's a zero or one
spot down that's a one so one plus zero
we get a one let's continue so from here
we'll look once uh spot directly to the
right that's one we'll look down that's
zero so
we'll put a 1 here again from here we'll
look one spot to the right that's a 1
we'll look one spot down now we get a 2
right because we're adding these two
values together that makes sense right
because amount 2 how many different ways
could we sum up to this amount too if we
had all three coins available to us
there are two ways right and from here
we'll look directly to the right by one
two plus directly below that's zero so
we'll put a two here from here again
directly to the right directly below 1
plus 2 that's going to be 3 and from
here again directly to the right and
directly below that's going to be 4. so
we get a solution of 4. is that correct
well when you come back and look at the
problem description with that example
yeah that's what the amount was that's
good now we're ready to dive into the
code okay so now let's jump into the
code and since this video is probably
already too long i don't want to spend
too much time coding it up so let me
just show you the code and it will be in
the description this time if you want to
copy and paste it or take a look at it
so this is the recursive solution the
time and space complexity is big o of n
times m just like i mentioned in the
explanation you can see that we have a
cache in this case the cache is the hash
map the base case is just as i mentioned
right so one is if we actually get to
the target amount that we're looking for
remember we're passing in two variables
the index and the amount a if we get to
the target amount then we're going to
return one if we go over the target
amount that's that means we cannot
possibly sum up to the amount we return
zero if we go out of bounds meaning i is
out of bounds right that basically means
now we we decided that we don't have any
coins available to us uh that's going to
be we're going to return zero as well in
that case uh and the fourth base case is
if we've already computed this if we've
already computed it we can take it
directly from our cache and then return
it the other case is now this is the
base case or not the base case this is
the recursive case right you can see i'm
calling dfs twice one is where i'm
calling dfs is where we are choosing the
coin that is at index i in that case we
leave i just as it is and then we say
okay the new amount that we have is a
whatever the amount that we previously
had plus whatever coin happens to be at
index i right so we're choosing the coin
at index i that's one decision the
second decision is if we skip the coin
at index i in that case the amount stays
the same right we skipped a coin so we
don't change the amount but we do have
to increment our index i because we're
skipping this coin right now we're going
to choose the next coin so that's the
main logic behind this and then whatever
the result of this happens to be we're
going to go ahead and throw it into our
cache and then return the value from the
cache and so that's the entire dfs all
you have to do is call the dfs starting
at index zero starting with our amount
being zero and then we can just return
that result right up above now i've copy
and pasted the dynamic programming
solution where we had to use two
dimensions of memory so this is the same
memory complexity big o of n multiplied
by m right this is the one that was
sub-optimal for dynamic programming so
you can see i'm using two dimensions for
the dp cache and then the logic of this
is pretty much the same as i showed
right we're going to be going from
starting at amount equals one uh we're
going to see how many different ways can
we sum up to that amount right and then
our index i
is uh going to be at the last coin so
length of the coins -1 where we only
have one coin available to us right i is
gonna be uh decremented each time
because we're gonna be adding more and
more available coins each time but so
suppose we had uh this many coins
available to us that's what i says and a
we're trying to sum up to this
particular amount what what is that
going to be well one decision is if we
skip the coin at index i which is just
going to be dp of a uh with i plus one
you can see that this line of code is
the exact same if you look below this
dfs is the exact same as this line of
code right you can see the parameters
are the exact same right all i'm doing
is passing in a i plus 1 here same thing
here right a i plus 1. now the other
case is going to be
with if we actually do use the coin at
index i right so we're going to take a
minus uh coins of i
why are we doing minus here instead of
plus down here well you could do it you
can implement it how you want i did it
like this because
a is the target amount if we use this
coin then we have a certain amount left
over now we're confirming that whatever
that amount left over is greater than or
equal to zero because if it's negative
that means we went over right that means
we use too many coins so if this is
greater than or equal to zero then this
line of code is just is completely
analogous to this dfs down here if you
can see it this dfs where we pass in i
uh a plus coins of i you can see that
instead of passing a plus coins of i'm
doing a minus coins of i
right but this is uh if you get confused
by this i would recommend going back to
that two-dimensional grid that i was
showing you because this is exactly the
same as that now last but not least i
have went ahead and copy and pasted my
code for the solution where the memory
complexity is actually just big o of n
the time complexity is the same as the
above solution but the memory complexity
is less you can see that that's exactly
what i'm doing here right we're not
actually using the full
memory we're not using two dimensions of
memory we just have one dimension and
you can see just like in the
two-dimensional matrix that i showed the
main difference between the above
solution and the below solution is just
the order that we're computing the uh
the two-dimensional grid right you can
see in this case the outer loop is we're
iterating through the amount and the
inner loop is where we're iterating
through the coins in the other case the
outer loop is iterating through the
coins and the inner loop is iterating
through the amount but other than that
the entire solution is pretty similar
right like here you can see i'm pretty
much just i have one row that i'm
maintaining out here and then i'm i'm
using next dp to be the next row that
we're computing and then at the end i'm
just reassigning dp to be next dp right
at any given point we're only going to
have two rows in memory we're not going
to have an entire two-dimensional grid
so i know this was really confusing and
this is probably a long video i wasn't
able to spend as much time on the code
as i would like but i hope that the
drawing explanation was able to help you
out this code will be in the description
if you want to take a look i guess let
me just run it and prove to you that it
works so i'll run the code that is below
which is the most optimal solution that
i was able to come up with the time
complexity is n by m and the memory
complexity is of n you can see on the
left that it does work and it's pretty
efficient so i hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon
thanks for watching